and we can we can get started right away
I'd like to invite the first panelists
and the chair professor Chatterjee
Elizabeth Cole ski and the other
panelists to come come to the table and
we can get started shall we begin so
welcome to the first session of the
conference the title of the first panel
is nation-state geographies identities
for things there I believe initially it
was framed around the question of
borders and defining borders but we
needn't stick to that question only
because there are many other things to
talk about and the panelists are all
very distinguished researchers Elizabeth
Cole ski who was one of our Columbia PhD
students now published a book she is
currently at villanova university so
welcome back to Colombia yes mean soy
Kia who is at the Arizona State
University a very distinguished
historian of Assam and willem van
schendel whom I think I've known for
about 30 years now something he looks
the same once again a very distinguished
historian who began work on agricultural
laborers in
in Bangladesh that's when I first met
him since then he's written on a large
number of subjects happy to do precisely
with migration borders on the eastern
part of India Bangladesh Burma that area
he's at the University of Amsterdam so
Elizabeth first what are what are the
time no so so basically we will then
stick to about what half an hour each no
20 minutes 20 minutes each and then we
can have enough discussion okay thank
you about two weeks ago on sep tember
30th i woke to the news that i had
killed a man Anwar al-awlaki who had
been on the US government's killer
capture list since april 2010 was
traveling in northern Yemen when his car
was bashed with Hellfire missiles fired
by CI operated Predator drones I don't
work for the CIA and I've never been to
Yemen yet as a citizen of a democracy
whose political power supposedly derived
from his people I am deeply troubled by
this act of murder committed in my name
if not actually by my hand critics of
Allah Keys killing have raised
constitutional questions about the
legality of a targeted assassination of
an American citizen without due process
a recent New York Times opinion piece by
Harvard Law Professor Jack Goldsmith
brushed such concerns aside by asserting
that due process quote depends on
context according to Goldsmith the Obama
administration acted justly by killing
an individual who threatened American
security outside the traditional
battlefield this argument is a logical
extension of the Bush administration's
position on unlawful enemy combatants
people unilaterally defined by the US
government as beings beyond the reach
and protections of international law I
am not terribly interested in the
question regarding the rights of
American citizens as I believe that
wantin murder is never a legitimate
means to pursue justice what I am more
interested in is how ideas about space
figure in modern legal regimes and how
speech acts enable legal acts that is
how describing people in certain sorts
of language defines what and can we but
what can and will be done to them under
the law allah ki was not just physically
outside the of US territory when he was
killed he was conceptually identified as
a subject who stood outside law how can
the state's application of law depend on
quote context when the rule of law is
meant to be a defining feature of the
modern state what are we to make of
these instances when the brute violence
of the modern state becomes so starkly
visible are these extraordinary moments
or do such summary killings reveal
something fundamental about the violent
and authoritarian core of the modern
state as our esteemed moderator part the
Chatterjee has demonstrated so
convincingly in his own work the history
of the colonial state is of crucial
interest to the study of the modern
state in general and to the study of the
independent nation states of South Asia
in particular as colonialism is the
context from which these states emerged
there its forms of government governance
kept largely intact thus I begin our
time together with his a historical
perspective on colonial law in South
Asia one would suggest the challenges of
thinking beyond security as our
conference beckons us to do the stain
sanction killing of a man on the
geographical fringes of Yemen has
resonated with me in a particularly
forceful way as it echoes my current
research on the history of law and
violence on the geographical fringes of
British India in what are now Pakistan's
federally administered tribal areas
British colonial officials viewed the
Northwest Frontier as the gateway to
india the road by which previous empires
had historically entered and conquered
the subcontinent they believed that the
security of British India depended upon
securing a strong military position on
this vulnerable land frontier
alternately using the carrots of
accommodation and
conciliation and the sticks of force and
repression they struggled for a century
to establish dominance over a people who
to borrow James Scott's formulation
seemed have mastered the art of not
being governed colonial cartography on
the frontier consisted of a double
border the durand line drawn in 1893
marked the external political boundary
separating Afghanistan from British
India do its eastleigh an internal
boundary referred to as the
administrative border which separate
separated what were called the tribal
excuse me the settled districts from the
tribal tracks the cartel the
cartographic distinction between the
settled districts and the tribal tracks
had a double meaning the car to the on
the one hand the cell district was an
area where a land survey and revenue
assessment had been done and where taxes
were collected on the other hand the
internal border separating the settled
districts from the tribal tracks was
structured to mark the limits of law
order and civilization in colonial
discourse the frontier tribes primarily
ethnic Pashtuns and the land they lived
on were defined as organic elements of
an inscrutable and slow changing natural
ecosystem one British offer wistfully
observed quote hidden away in dark
inhospitable nullahs instill darker
ravines in lonely mountain passes and on
barren winslet windswept plains dwell
appeal the human flotsam and jetsam of
the past this mountainous geography and
the tough type of man it supposedly
produced savage chivalrous desperate
adventurous alluring wrote Lord kurzin
were seen to be the main obstacles to
British influence this discourse a
frontier other pneus extended beyond the
linguistic realm to define what could
and would be done to the colonial state
to local people in ways that had serious
and deadly implications in the mid 19th
century the colonial government created
a modern judicial machinery for all of
British India establishing a
hierarchical system of law courts and a
codified system of law to be a quiet
applied equally at least in theory to
all subjects on the sub calm
however the logic and red dirt rhetoric
that defined colonial frontier policy
rested on the assumption that
exceptional circumstances demanded
exceptional treatment and the frontier
was that quintessentially exceptional
space the anglo-indian codes were
derided by British administrators as
being unsuited to local conditions which
required a quote rough-and-ready
procedure better adapted to this
primitive space colonizing Europeans
according to historian Lauren Benton
viewed mountainous regions as spaces of
political isolation violence and
backwardness requiring a certain kind
and amount of law to match their lower
level of civilizational development
frontier officials who press the
Government of India for special frontier
legislation applied this very logic
arguing that the man on the spot needed
a freer hand unconstrained by legal
rules and technicalities this was the
19th century colonial version of
Goldsmith's argument that law depends on
context for what is here modern
rationale indispensable a legal rule
there becomes a bothersome and
dispensable technicality thus at the
very moment when a normative legal order
was established for British India a
parallel legal system was created on the
frontier comprised of the frontier
crimes regulation which remains the
legal framework under which the FATA
territories are governed by the Pakistan
government and the Punjab murders
outrageous act these laws vastly broaden
the power of colonial officials
disposing of the legal niceties
introduced into India by the British
themselves including due process a
written trial record formal rules of
evidence the right to legal
representation the right to appeal one's
conviction and so forth the Punjab
murders outrageous act for ins the
subject of my talk today the frontier
was brought within the ambit of colonial
authority in 18-49 by sick 1867 16
Europeans had been killed or badly
wounded in the region prompting the
official demand for special legislation
the violence directed against their own
women fortified colonial ideas about the
brutal and bloodthirsty nature of the
local pushed in population and
strengthened Britain's resolved to teach
the tribes a lesson of obedience on
februari 28th 1866 mrs. Ashton brandreth
the wife of an English lieutenant in co
hoc was being carried by her servants in
a jump on when a man approached and
fired his pistol at such close range
that mrs. brandreth sighs eyelashes and
hair was singed the bullet passed across
her collarbone and through the front of
her neck sparing mrs. Brown with serious
injury her assailant samad was
immediately apprehended and tried by the
local magistrate he confessed to the
crime claiming that quote I came
straight to Co hot to kill a european i
formed the design thinking it was a
meritorious action having heard it was a
meritorious action from symboles abdera
some years ago and thought i should
achieve a name for myself by doing it
three days later the trial proceedings
were reviewed by the peshawar division
commissioner junior Beecher who
convicted samad of attempted murder and
causing hurt in his judgment feature
remarked that quote the fierce
fanaticism directed against the lives of
the ruling race of India is a special
danger of this frontier and one which
requires to be taken into account in
determining punishment in my judgment it
is necessary to adopt more than ordinary
measures to prevent an evil so great and
so fraught with political consequences
in mid 19th century England the notion
of punishment being proportional to the
crime worked to soften the severity of
the bloody capital code in mid 17th
century colonial India by contrast the
idea of proportional punishment
sharpened the edge of the law enhancing
the penalties meted out to those who
dared to threaten the lives of the
ruling race for attempting to murder a
white woman beater sentence samad to
death and hanged him the same day in
samara lee ordering Samantha execution
Beecher exceeded the maximum punishment
allowed under the indian penal code for
attempted murder the maximum punishment
was transportation he also exceeded his
duty
authority by failing to request
confirmation for the death sentence from
the punjab chief chief court his actions
were subsequently upheld and excused by
the government of india the punjab
government viewed the attack on mrs.
Brann Ruth as something more than an
ordinary attempted murder and as this
was the third attempt on a European
committed on the frontier within the
past year they asked the government for
special legislation to enable district
officials to deal with such a tax quote
more severely and promptly than is
authorized by the indian penal code and
the code of criminal procedure the
Punjab murderers outrageous act passed
in 1867 gave frontier officials the
power to summarily try and execute
alleged fanatics who murdered or
attempted to murder servants of the
Queen or other persons on the spot in
proceedings that exceeded their ordinary
judicial authority magistrates were
ordinarily restricted from trying
offences punishable with death life
imprisonment or or imprisonment
exceeding two years under the Punjab
murderers outrages Act a new class of
criminals identified as fanatics were
deprived of the rights and procedures
mandated by the ordinary law including
the right to legal counsel and the right
to have a capital sentence confirmed by
a higher tribunal not only could a
fanatic be tried and executed on the
same day his property could be seized
and his body disposed of as the
government saw fit the most common
method of disposing of the corpses of
executed fanatics in the 19th century
was to burn them the annihilation of the
fanatics corpse with a symbolic device
of colonial justice designed to secure
that the executed executed man could not
achieve the eternal martyrdom he
supposedly sought in this instance
British legislators used their knowledge
of Muslim religious beliefs to enhance
the force of the law as they assumed
that muslims believe that a Muslim whose
body was burnt after death would be
denied a place in paradise the burning
of bodies was meant to strike terror
into
be killers by taking the quote kick out
of a people who otherwise seem to have
no fear of the state the notion of a
troubled frontier populated by turbulent
tribes legitimized acts of violence and
coercion committed by the British
themselves against local communities in
the first 30 years of frontier rule
there were no less than 40 punitive
expeditions in which entire villages
crops and livestock were burned to the
ground by colonial troops these brutal
military strategies were intended to
project colonial power and to compel
compliance through intimidation as a
swift in certain hand was supposedly the
only thing such people understood johnk
poetically expressed the logic of this
policy when he wrote quote we cannot
reign wild horses with silken braids
echoes of this view can certainly be
heard in what Derek Gregory refers to as
the colonial present from the British
perspective the Northwest Frontier was
in a perpetual state of crisis some
administrators described emergency as
the normal condition of things in the
region quote the frontier is always a
powder magazine one observed and even at
the cost of sacrificing the ideas of
theoretical Liberty it is sent is
essential to keep the match away from
the powder keeping the match away from
the powder entail tipping the balance
between liberty and government
completely in favor in executive power
under laws such as the murderous
outrages Act the Northwest Frontier
offers a historical kasidie to consider
giorgio agamben state of exception a
paradigm of modern governance based on
emergency without visible end a sheila
mem Bay has provocatively extended
gambians insights about the nature of
the modern state to the colonial world
defining the colony as a state where the
controls and guarantees of judicial
order can be suspended and where
according to MMB the sovereign right to
kill is not subject to any rule
according to a member the total control
found in the colony was enabled by quote
the exercise of a power outside the law
there is no date that there is no doubt
that the
colonial state on the north west
frontier was in am Bambi's chilling
formulation a terror formation however
it would be inaccurate to state that
colonial violence was exercised outside
the law to the contrary frontier
legislation was specifically designed to
extend colonial authority within a legal
framework the murderous outrageous act
was a special regulation designed for a
special space overrun with murderous
fanatics determined to kill servants of
the Queen it provided the colonial
sovereign with virtually unbridled
authority over the colonized subject
including the right to summarily try and
execute a person in unrecorded
proceedings proceedings where the
accused had no right to legal
representation or appeal but the
sovereigns right to kill did not operate
outside the law for the law expressly
provided for such killings borrowing
Goldsmith language as the context
demanded the murderous outrages Act
reveals the colonial state as a state of
terror even as it defined itself as a
state against terror controlling
supposedly uncover nabol and fanatical
people who could literally be disposed
of as the government saw fit in the
colonial world emergency powers were a
constant feature of governance rather
than a provisional response to temporary
conditions and stoller has aptly
described Imperial formations as
policies where exceptions are a norm in
colonial India where the balance between
state power and personal liberty was
consistently weighted towards the
sovereign in a way that was not possible
for sustained periods of time in Britain
one finds zones of varying discrete
varying degrees of exclusion and
suspended rights within the same broad
territorial framework the Indian in most
of india had fewer basic rights than the
britain did the Indian on the north-west
frontier was denied what hannah arendt
calls a right to have rights under the
parallel system of frontier legislation
that / vases the pervasive legalism in
the British Empire the notion that
colonial power and legitimacy rested on
a rule of and by law required ways of
securing control within a legal
framework post-colonial states of South
Asia have largely retained the laws and
legal institute
asians created by their former colonial
masters including the extraordinary
regulations that legalized the state's
extraordinary use of force and coercion
hence I ask you how are we able to think
beyond security thank you thank you very
much Elizabeth yes ma'am thank you I
want to thank the organizers for
inviting us to this conference and most
of all for making it a Bangladesh
Pakistan conference which is rather
unique not to have India butting in
between and particularly given that I
velocities I had to make that yes I take
this as an entry point from actually
another piece of article that I read by
Ron Oggo ha not home in the Empire where
he uses Orwell story of questioning the
possibility of freedom are we really
free to act beyond the institutions that
control us taking that as my entry point
I asked about the legacy of 1971 and is
it possible to move beyond the narrative
that has been created both in Pakistan
Bangladesh and India about a story of
violence and hate rather I searched for
a possible place of freedom on the
platform of humanity in San yet in South
Asia like Orwell the survivors of 1971
asked will reseach the opportunity of
recognizing our insomnia and act as free
agents for rewriting the narrative of
the war can we break the cycle of hate
produce and deployed by those in power
these questions of survivals allow a
different and unique narrative to emerge
shifting the focus from external
institution and state actors to the
internal domain of people's memories
preserved by individuals the new and
humanistic narrative of survivors is at
the heart of my paper survivors
narrative from Pakistan and Bangladesh
produced in the world of abdullahi and I
mean a kinder gentler story based on the
understanding of humanity for imagining
a better future in the region this
approach is particularly situated with
the ongoing conversation of jazz
that is going on in Bangladesh under the
war criminal tribunal this is of course
a different reading from that the
presentation is divided into two
sections and I'll very briefly go
through both of them one is the concept
of stranger the stranger which is very
different in the Islamic concept which
is based on Oh mwah the stranger is a
guess however in the case of Pakistan
the stranger became the enemy the enemy
was identified as a Bengali body against
which violence was allowed taking that
narrative as again a beginning point
coming out of survivors of 1971 I
highlight the Islamic principle of
repentance toba that many of the
perpetrators spoke about and ask for
forgiveness and compassion rahem that
religion offers in order to reconstitute
the principle of the rights of people
haku caliban to understand this Islamic
concept of course one has to get into
the question of in Sam and I will not go
into here if you have questions I can
sort of talk about it further this I
think if we can return to the survivors
narrative that raised these questions of
Taba in San coca-cola bad week I suggest
it is a possible way to look for justice
now placing it within the context of the
history of Pakistan three 1971 I start
the story with ayub khan in 1958 who
assumed who soon after assuming the
position of Pakistan decided to look for
ways how to create a narrative of the
Pakistani people based on Islamic
nationalism because the only thing on
which Pakistan are all united as he said
was a fear of Hindu domination having
established a common ground for
pakistanis to be a unified nation he
identified the army as a true protectors
of Islam and nation the Pakistani people
and soldiers were encouraged to imagine
themselves as the progeny of successful
and fears military heroes from Central
Asia and Arabian Peninsula and they were
set in sharp contrast the Hindu baniya
and sedentary agriculture class of
presents the document title Pakistani
national engine was created by order of
Ayub Khan
as a blueprint for Islam izing pakista
the document asserted that amongst the
first settlers were the Arabs and whose
whose culture is still evident in an
area of West Pakistan however the people
of East Pakistan may seem to be closer
to the Hindus of been gone further the
document said that only the path that
not only had the Muslims been the rulers
and the Hindus the rule but that they
were diametrically opposed to one
another so you can imagine by doing this
kind of binary of Muslim in West
Pakistan coming from Arabia versus the
Bengalis as part of East Pakistan
connected with India closer to Hindu the
decedent rahbaniya class a real kind of
division was created it was accepted an
official level that the Hindu of east
part of the Muslim the Hindu like Muslim
of East Pakistan had to be Islam minds
and for this another new version of
history was written in 1965 again by
orders of Ayub Khan to make East
Pakistan history of Muslim history the
group that of course was identified to
be the biggest problem are the Muslim
bengalis of East Pakistan because the
language was viewed to be closer to
sanskrit the food and clothes where Dean
has not truly Islamic and the people
were considered to be susceptible to
tremendous influence of west part of
west bengal particularly having
communist inclination the military's
grand scheme of reducing the bengalis
into subject group of course flame the
fires of Bengali nationalism and
provoked multiple unrest throughout East
Pakistan in the 1960s in an attempt to
give Pakistan a new leads to life via
con as so many of you know who became
the martial law administrator after our
Yukon held election in 1970 and of
course this election the results of the
election were not accepted and led to
the deployment of the army on March
twenty-fifth nineteen seventy one under
the so-called thing operation
searchlight to teach the Bengalis a
lesson at the end of the war we know
that Pakistan broke up into two leading
to park west pakistan becoming pakistan
the truncated Pakistan that we know
today and
East Pakistan emerging as Bangladesh
what appears to be the case in this
particular instance is that
linguistically and historically from
1947 to 1971 there were the
metamorphosis and shifting change of who
is a Pakistani within Pakistan the
creation of West Pakistan s core
concomitantly reduced East Pakistan into
periphery and the bengali ppl morphed
into the status of outsiders aliens
hindu life and ultimately became
strangers in their own land the Bengali
stranger within Pakistan deemed as enemy
deserved no consideration and goodwill
contrary to the concept of stranger as
guest was treated with kindness in the
early Muslim polities Pakistan's actions
was thus inconsistent with its
representation of itself as an Islamic
Republic in turn we also know that the
Bengali majority in East Pakistan viewed
the Pakistanis with invest within East
Pakistan particularly the Ordo speaking
people as their enemies there was a
proliferation of enemies a common
experience for everyone was the loss of
honor and their sense of humanity during
my research in both Bangladesh and
Pakistan I discussed with a variety of
people the problem of other rising I had
over 250 interviews and conversations
with Bengali in ordos speaking people
particularly women and over 150
interviews with perpetrators in Pakistan
and Bangladesh of course this is not an
exhaustive number but the range that I
covered in different areas the area that
i covered was quite extensive almost all
the survivors i met spoke very mostly
remorsefully of the loss of religions
and human values I can't explain all of
this in the short presentation but i
will very quickly tell two small stories
one is of a Hindu woman Aparna who was
raped by her neighbors and Pakistani
soldiers and at the end of this event of
course as she says my life is not even
like of a human being nobody has even
recognized what I had suffered this is
not unique for a bengali hindi woman to
say so because even Bihari Muslim women
today even living in East in Bangladesh
talk about inhumanity of women bingo of
Bordeaux speaking with woman's life in
Bangladesh juxtaposed to this victims
narrative of dehumanization
is a perpetrators narrative from
Pakistan who also talks about how he
joined the Pakistan Army and having
joined the army having been posted to
East Pakistan the crimes that he
committed he said that he recognized
even as he was doing the violence that
this was not what one human being does
to another human being as he sort of
concluded in one short meeting that I
had in the first time he said insaniyat
had died but then thereafter he had
become a poww and in the poww camp he
had an opportunity to revisit the
violence that he and others committed
and in his cell there were 36 men and he
said when we started talking about it we
realized we have committed guna and
having committed buna we had to do toba
but taba is not enough because again as
he said insaniyat had died one may
evaluate the Pakistani statement the
parkside soldier statement as a cop-out
mechanism to come to terms with the past
without having to deal with a victim
suffering this would be a hasty
conclusion to understand what this
soldier is conveying one has to place
into context the Islamic concept of guna
committed against another human being it
is considered to be the most heinous
crime that even God cannot pardon unless
the perpetrators forgiven by the victim
the admission by the soldier perpetrator
that is actually in Bengal considered
constituted guna is significant because
it takes responsibility and becomes
aware that he has to bear the
consequences in this life and in the
hereafter this realization of course
does not come easy his awareness of his
fragile insomnia makes him even more
vulnerable he has to live with the
knowledge and in an indeterminate state
because gonna have insomnia cannot be
redeemed without the victims forgiveness
this is this is not just the only person
as I said I had spoken to over 150
perpetrators and very quickly I will
give you a couple of names because they
had allowed me to share this with you
one who is a crop circle very well-known
and he said that in 1971 he could not
take sides with in the war because it
meant dividing up his parents one parent
came from East Pakistan and the other
parent was from West Pakistan from
sialkot he said he was he was actually
court-martial for his dubious allegiance
Alexa hemsida Yakov conquer our aliaga
another Ally Masood mufti muhammad
shafiq zahid Zaman ria shipra syed abdul
nasir samsudin and others you have a
great importance to the issue of
conscience is a meal in choosing to
question the violence that they had
committed during the war now having
collected all these all these
testimonies from people who go back and
forth between remembering the war as
something that was duty and then
recognizing it was violence and not
asking for a different voice of humanity
of insomnia what do we do with it that
is the big question Bangladesh's
response has been to come up with
something called a war criminal tribunal
in Pakistan of course there is a total
silence about this issue and perhaps
writing about these issues may bring to
light some of the things that they want
to talk about because perpetrators in
there silent minds do talk about it or
work or talk about in the mind but have
never birbal eyes it so taking up taking
into consideration that both Bangladesh
and Pakistan are Muslim majority
countries I would like to suggest as I
said using the term in sanya that they
bring it to the discussion as a possible
place to start thinking what can we do
as far as reconciliation for justice
traditional speaking in Islam there are
two kinds of rights the rights of God
hakuba Allah and the rights of people
who Copely bad the hakuouki bad rides
are basically secular rights that are
unconditional and fundamental and cannot
be denied to any person rate that was a
crime committed by men against women is
a matter of hookah calabar in the pre
Islamic cultures the reaction to rape
was retaliatory violence but in Islam it
says it should be proportionate violence
so that justice is restored to reduce
the severity of retributive punishment
people are encouraged to show mercy and
compassion raha a rape victims mercy to
the perpetrator I mean yeah is based on
an active process of seeking forgiveness
by the victim and the victim and the and
the victim showing raham towards the
victimized
this is not very different from the
Christian concept of forgiveness to some
extent but in the Islamic case the right
is given to people not to some
institution it is also encourages
victims and perpetrators to see one
another as people which is not very
different again from the guardian
concept of approaching British colonial
policies and asking it to be redeemed
rather than blaming the English as a
community of a presence so Islamic
restorative justice assumes that peace
is possible after violence with a
reciprocating of forgiveness which the
victims right to give over at home of
course it has to be come from the
victimizers themselves the holistic
approach has to come from the victimizer
in Pakistan and effort was made by the
women's Action forum to apologize on
behalf of the Pakistani soldiers but if
we take the concept of coca-cola bad it
cannot be done on behalf of someone else
it has to be done by the people who
commit crimes so beyond the individuals
understanding of the crimes the states
of Pakistan and Bangladesh are
ultimately responsible in encouraging
men to fight and encouraging men to
speak about the violence they had
committed and take responsibility for
the actions that they had done at this
juncture it seems almost impossible
because neither Bangladesh or Pakistan
are willing to talk about it so even
though you may have a language a
cultural religious language to seek
justice between victims and perpetrators
it is not yet come to a point where one
can discuss about it in it as a
historian I think the beginning point is
to write about these issues create these
narrative and open the way for the
nations and the states to talk about it
so I'm going to stop here
Philip like just mean I'd like to start
by thanking the organizers for including
me in this conference especially because
conferences linking Pakistan and
Bangladesh are extremely rare and
jasmine has just pointed out need to be
more frequent the theme of this panel is
nation-state geographies and identities
I'll try to say a few words about all of
these taking my cue from geographies
South Asians know only too well that
past territorial manipulations cast huge
shadows over the present the
subcontinent's modern history is
characterized by a bewildering array of
administrative reshuffles and re
alignments its territorial tree of life
looks more like a thicket venatori how
geographies affect the identities is
important and yet the connections
between territorial manipulation and
changing identities in South Asia have
been studied very selectively to what
extent have identities resulted from
territorial change and to what extent
have I have identity produced
territorial change we certainly lack an
overview even for parts of the
subcontinent so what I will do here is a
cursory examination of just one reason
now known to us as Bangladesh and
earlier as East Bengal and East Pakistan
and suggest some comparative
possibilities contemporary Bangladesh is
the geographical result of three main
types of territorial manipulation first
reallocation in which territories moved
from one administrative unit to another
this was a frequent occurrence but
perhaps the best-known was the shift of
the disk
select from the province of Bengal to
that of Assam in 1874 and its partial
reallocation to Bengal in 1947 second is
exclusion in which territories removed
from general administrative practice and
brought under special local rule in
Bangladesh a good example are the
Chittagong Hill Tracts a district for
which a special regulation was created
in the year 1900 remnants of which are
still in place another example was
northern Mymensingh district which was
turned into a partially excluded area
from nineteen thirty six to nineteen
forty seven giving rise to identities
that still play a role in local politics
and the third form of territorial
manipulation is he sure in which an
administrative unit is split for
Bangladesh the most important were the
creation of the province of eastern
Bengal and Assam from nineteen oh five
to nineteen or 1911 the breakup of
colonial India first into British Burma
and British India in 1937 and then into
the independent states of Pakistan and
India and forty-seven followed by the
Fisher of Pakistan into Bangladesh and a
truncated Pakistan in 1971 such
reallocations exclusions and fissures
shape not only contemporary Bangladesh
but also Pakistan and India and this
experience makes them such a rich case
for comparison three states that grew
out of a single colony they took
different directions and thus are living
proof of the connected but unpredictable
nature of post-colonial trajectories
Bangladesh provides an especially
instructed case it's special interest
lies in the fact that in significant
ways it has moved beyond the issues that
still have such a powerful hold on
Pakistan and India Bangladesh has moved
further away
from the trauma of partition than the
other parts of Earth's while British
India yes it took another huge trauma to
make this possible the game changer was
the liberation war of 1971 it turned
Bangladesh into a society beyond
partition logic the logic of homelands
for Muslim and non-muslim South Asians
and because it is no longer grounded in
that logic its identity has been hard to
define unlike Indians and Pakistanis
Bangladesh's do not really have markers
like Kashmir to remind them almost daily
of the pain of partition this had made
has made it easier for the memory to
fade but it is not just that the
partition of 47 has been superseded by
the partition of 71 and that the older
Troma has faded it is also that in
Bangladesh the events of 1947 have
become a very inconvenient truth the
memory of an erroneous choice the forced
marriage a dream turned into a nightmare
in Bangladesh therefore 47 is actively
forgotten it has been consciously erased
this presents a major contrast with
Pakistan and India both Pakistan and
India continued to celebrate partition
and to legitimize themselves were
referring to it Bangladesh never does
the war of 71 which freed Bangladesh
from West Pakistani control also freed
it from the menurkey ISM that still
haunts india-pakistan relations seen
from post 71 Bangladesh South Asia
provides a three-cornered game in terms
of strategic alliances as well as
identities and the spell of 47 has been
broken in this one in this sense
Bangladesh is the one that got away
therefore trying to understand
contemporary Bangladesh by applying the
standard tools of indo-pakistan
scholarship is
helpful just as unhelpful as the
practice among some South Asia scholars
of overlooking Bangladesh when making
general pronouncements about the region
because it refracts the light slightly
differently Bangladesh exemplifies the
comparative possibilities within South
Asian Studies let me give a few brief
examples narratives of decolonization
the complexity of South Asian stories of
emancipation dearies put crudely the
Indian case is relatively simple and
straightforward a classical story of
struggle against European colonial
rulers the Pakistani case adds a layer
it is a story of liberation from both
European rule and Hindu dominance
occurring at the same time and the
Bangladeshi case adds yet yet another
layer it is the story of triple
emancipation from European rule and
Hindu domination occurring at the same
time and from Muslim domination
occurring later even this third event is
understood as a story of decolonization
because Bangladesh historians insist on
analyzing the 24 year period of United
Pakistan as a period of colonial rule
the second example is phases of
nationalism given the different
narratives of emancipation it stands to
reason that Bangladeshi nationalism
developed very differently from Indian
and Pakistani nationalism there are
people alive in Bangladesh who still
remember feeling part of the Indian
nation as envisaged by the likes of
Gandhi and Nehru in the 1940s then
learning to be a Pakistani and now being
a member of the Bangladeshi nation the
their experience of what you could call
serial unlearning of previous national
belongings links up with the experience
of elderly Pakistanis but contrast with
that of Indians it remains largely
and explored the development of
Bangladeshi nationalism preceded the
creation of the state of Bangladesh it
was an example of an identity creating a
territory it shows two distinct phases
from roughly 1965 to 1975 was a period
of strident nationalism based on ethnic
pride expressed in symbols such as the
Bengali language and the Utopia of the
golden Bengal it was informed by a
prominent transnational trend of the
time state socialism yet within a
capitalist context it was directed
against West Pakistan and after
liberation in 71 against Pakistan the
United Nations and China the second
phase began in 1975 and continues today
it can be described as instrumental
nationalism it has toned down the
rhetoric of the earlier phase while
still employing many of its symbols it
has moved firmly away from socialist
models and has rediscovered is Islamic
identity it is also more distrustful of
India without getting close to Pakistan
link to this is the third example about
shifting cultural orientations the
creation of new national cultures Indian
and Pakistani after 1947 led to a
serious rethinking of cultural
connections in East Pakistan the 50s and
60s saw the emergence of what Columbia
University Scholar Raonic jahan has
called a vernacular elite these people
were Bengali speaking Bengali schooled
at mostly small town backgrounds and
were culturally East bengoli they were
quite distinct from the padrona cultural
elite that had dominated 347 Bengal and
most of whom had left the country and
were now in Calcutta East Pakistan's
vernacular elite consciously distance
itself from Calcutta cultural
girls as well as from the West Pakistani
and/or do models that were being
propagated by the Pakistan state the
Bengali language movement that emerged
was not only emancipatory with regard to
West Pakistan Lima models but also with
regard to the Calcutta model for the
elite of East Pakistan the focal point
of bang bang godinez shifted away from
West Bengal Calcutta faded and its
models opinions pronunciation and
politics became less relevant the rise
of strident nationalism in the 60s
highlighted the East Bengali character
of the language movement it was a
Bengali pneus that was proudly dark
eccentric a trend that strengthened
further after Bangladesh became an
independent state Bangladesh trajectory
of elite formation provides an
instructive contrast with India and
Pakistan as a case of triple elimination
it is more complex than either of them
47 so East Pakistan's mainly Hindu elite
decimated being replaced largely by a
new West Pakistani elite 71 in turn saw
the wholesale retreat of this elite from
East Bengal at the same time the rising
ver natural elite was ravaged by
targeted killings thus Bangladesh was
born with a tiny privileged group that
had little experience of statecraft and
international affairs both 71 lavish
development aid allowed the meteoric
rise of a new elite closely linking
state NGO and foreign ngos and foreign
donors the first decade of the 21st
century so the power base of this a day
lead erode as other sources of power
became available trade industry and
remittances
complicated mergers between these groups
have today created an inviting national
elite with our deep historical roots
quite unlike its counterparts in
Pakistan and India the final example is
state institutions in Bangladesh state
institutions also provide an interesting
base for comparison with Pakistan and
India the joint origins in a fairly
unified colonial system are still
visible in terms of both form and
bureaucratic culture but mark difference
that differences have also appeared it
is no surprise that Bangladesh resembles
Pakistan more than India because India
went its own way after 47 whilst East
and West Pakistan went through similar
processes of institutional change till
71 but after that Bangladesh vomited on
its own course combining colonial
legacies and Pakistan era innovations
with new policies and institutions it is
instructive to compare these think of
the position of the judiciary and the
Armed Forces the systems of public
education the institutions of local
representation or consider the very
different approaches these three
countries developed towards their ethnic
minorities or more specifically minority
areas that were put under special
regulations and sometimes special
ministries for example Pakistan's Fatah
or federally administered tribal areas
we just heard about them in an earlier
phase Bangladesh's Chittagong Hill
Tracts and India's northeast the
divergence the divergent solutions that
the states sought for other similar
problems of managing cultural plurality
show how little these were determined by
the joint colonial mode from which they
emerged
all of this certainly has something to
do with the conference theme beyond
security but let me conclude with
another aspect of the link between
geographies and identities that relates
even more directly to security concerns
territorial conditions continue to have
a strong impact on Bangladeshi
identities because the country is
territorially compromised in many places
it had what it has not been able to
establish where its borders with
neighboring India and Bangladesh are
located nothing is more unnerving to a
new modern state than not being able to
define the limits of your neighbors
territorial control these border
uncertainties are rooted largely in a
shoddily executed partition in 1747 and
has festered ever since of course over
the years many attempts have been made
to resolve the issues sometimes
successfully but several major
disagreements remain India and East
Pakistan Bangladesh can look back on a
number of unimplemented agreements at
prime ministerial level notably the new
Nehru agreement of 58 and the mujib
Indira agreement of 74 just a few weeks
ago a similar agreement was made between
Sheikh Hasina and manmohan singh it will
be interesting to see if this new round
of reallocation exclusion and fischer
can be implemented if it can however it
will not cover a number of key security
issues for example the maritime
boundaries of the two countries which as
you may know are currently a case in the
permanent court of arbitration in The
Hague being territorial compromised is a
condition that Bangladesh shares with
India and Pakistan these states frayed
edges affect their behavior towards
their own citizens as well as towards
those of the neighboring states create
defensive national identity
and heightened security angst in
Bangladesh territorial uncertainty and
resulting frequent border clashes and
killings have had a strong impact on
identity formation visa V India in its
more moderate forms Bangladesh enos
today is proudly non-indian in its more
outspoken forms it is fiercely
anti-indian in Bangladesh each border
confrontation acts as a reminder of the
fragility and insecurity of the national
beyond this identities in Bangladesh are
anything but hermod homogeneous or
static it may be helpful to think of
them as khalid kaleidoscopic just as the
slightest movement of the kaleidoscope
produces a new configuration of brightly
colored bits of glass identities in
Bangladesh have a tendency to
reconfigure in southern surprising and a
but apparently patent patent ways in
recently years the most brightly colored
pieces in the mix have been of various
types the strident and industrial
nationalism ideas of Islamic decency
justice and order identities within the
larger category of Bengali whether
siletti or chit ago nyan or Hindu or
Christian and identities beyond that
category the rights of ethnic minorities
ranging from indigenous populations to
all do speaking stranded pakistanis and
finally trans national identities linked
to cyber connectivity diasporic
Bangladeshi communities and
environmental concerns the people in
charge of the Bangladesh state have
found themselves on shaky ground even
after 40 years of state the state elite
feels relatively fragile compared to its
Indian and Pakistani counterparts often
disunited and pulled in different
directions by kaleidoscopic identity
changes in society
although a sense of national identity
has flourished internally it remains
sharply fractured and the object of
intense public controversy this
kaleidoscopic attend intensity since by
adesh society apart from both Pakistan
in India as a result the Pakistan state
has found it much more difficult than
back then so the Bangladesh state has
found much more difficult than Pakistan
and India to be effective in projecting
a stable vision of the nation and its
security in this brief presentation I
have touched on the geographical
uncertainties that contribute to
security angst and hiding behind
national frameworks these the result in
worrying erasers for example there are
still Pakistanis historians of Pakistan
who erased East Pakistan from their
analyses such deliberate blindness is
similar to that of scholars of
Bangladesh who reduced the 24-year
Pakistan experience to merely a demonic
prelude to independence more comparative
approaches are beginning to emerge but
they need far more support and teamwork
that has been possible so far this
conference could be the start of such a
bigger effort thank you well thanks to
wonderfully self-disciplined presenters
we have at least 20 minutes probably a
little longer for discussion so floor is
open
yes
could you instances
could you also introduce yourself
briefly just your name my name is chilly
naman port I thank the panel is for very
informative presentations I was
wondering if each panelist yeah it's
okay it's okay thank you if you can
perhaps in one or two sentences
elaborate on what you see is the main
issues now in pakistan and bangladesh if
you have to pick one or two issues that
they are dealing with today that need to
be reconciled for the security issue and
for for them as a nation going forward
what would those be pops could be pull
together a few questions and then you
can yeah maybe so if there are others
yes
my name is Geeta say girl thank you for
all your presentations actually had
comments come questions for all of you
and going backwards I was a little
surprised by your designation of
bangladesh's not having as I may have
got it wrong but a sort of secure sense
of security or a sense of a nation
because of these border disputes and so
on there are many measures talking about
security and Richard you might say
Bangladesh is done extraordinarily well
as you said in terms of the money that's
gone in for development maternal
mortality and there are lot of issues in
terms of human security in which it is
doing rather better than all of its
neighbors and in relation to that i
would say that some of the comments you
made about partition I think you're
absolutely right that the experience of
partition and bandages has been largely
raised but I don't know partition being
separated in India and I'd be surprised
if it's celebration pakistan i think
independence is celebrated and partition
is commemorated or mourn certainly and
india and i think that we have to make a
distinction between the two with yasmin
our was fascinated by your account of
interviewing perpetrators from the
Pakistani side and you know the sense of
repentance and all of that but don't you
think that one of the ways of bringing
together a narrative is not going to
come from States but from people
recognizing this and that actually
something like the war crimes tribunal
could be a forum in which Pakistanis who
are willing to speak out about it with
the work you've done if they spoke that
that would be a very important national
narrative that actually came from people
and to Elizabeth um your description of
the frontier regulations and the big
state of exceptionalism of the frontier
was fascinating but the question that I
want to ask is that what disturbs me in
having been part of the anti-war
movement and so on in the West is the
way in which the state of exceptionalism
is in fact reinforced by the discourses
of people who opposed to the
interventions and so on so while
you know there's a very strong discourse
which says that precisely that
Afghanistan is unguardable the frontiers
uncomfortable Imran Khan standing as a
presidential candidate is promising to
keep the parallel legal systems you know
as in return for security you know jihad
but keep your own systems and there have
been Democratic movements from the
ground that are demanding removal of
that so I think it's very dangerous when
Western movements who think they're
supporting people in facing the war on
terror actually reinforced some of these
discourses of exceptionalism and lack of
interest in democratic rights and I
wondered what your comment was on that
per se i have a question for you asked
me a couple of questions what is that
your caricature of the Bengali Muslims
which you said are you was responsible
for I think that that predates are you
buy at least 120 years this whole idea
of how North Indians Muslims saw
themselves to be superior to any other
Muslim in in South Asia and yes I that
that itself is an interesting way of how
wrong East Pakistan wars and some ways
you know how it created that so I just
wanted I know it's not it's not right to
blame you or you could you should blame
it for lots of other things but maybe
not seeing the way and the Pakistani the
Western West Pakistani people and the
and everybody else I seeing Bengali
Muslims and inferior I think that's
something that is part of North Western
North Indian Muslim tradition so say
you're done with Han being I think very
vocal about it the second question is
about this idea of insomnia and
repentance does it have to be in an
Islamic paradise he does rahem toba guna
is there a way of repenting without
turning to God
and seeking forgiveness without you know
you make the distinction between a
coca-cola bath and who couldn't you know
God and the world but I think even your
references to individuals looking at
other individuals as symbols for
repentance seem to be very la me or
Muslim but I think I'm sure there are
other ways to repent who's next Dina
such a question for a villain about a
lead formation and in golly nationalism
I thought that you perhaps overstated
that is the rejection of a relationship
between Bangladesh and West Bengali
Bengali knees and I think it seems to me
that there's something at the core of
Bengali Bangladeshi nationalism that
there's a real ambivalence and
contradiction about what it means to be
a Bengali that that actually haunts the
political system entirely as well as all
of the cultural politics and it really
is about why we have a state that's a
bingo least 84 Bengalis but it's not
part of west bengal there that that I
think there's this cartographic anxiety
is beyond sort of with the cheetah more
holes and you know all of these other
territories and I while there are a lot
of people who want to be Bangladesh's as
well as Bengalis there are a lot of
there there is this supposedly
progressive Bengali cultural and
nationalist movement that wants to see
itself as part of a larger Indian under
the sheathing and I wonder if you could
speak to that should we stop here and
then go take another run ok please
respond and then we'll take a second
round
okay okay i'll start the bidding it's a
good position your first question about
what are the common perhaps issues that
can be addressed in a very short way I
in in the case of Pakistan and
Bangladesh both of them I see are going
through major islamization process of a
rather violent kind which is in a way
putting women once again out of that
conversation so that's one of a common
problem I see actually in both those
places the actors are different but of
course and the methods are a little
different but they are common and I
think because it's common but it is
disconnected they are not connected
these movements they probably have
networks I don't know they talk about
all of those issues in American foreign
politics i'm not one of those to learn a
lot about it so i think the disconnect
is also creating an indifference as if
their national problems rather than
their regional issues that we have to
deal with that's one of two ways that i
see our common yet disconnected do you
want to take that
don't respond to that then maybe I'll
take all my questions together and
answer all of them together the question
about my I think Amber's question and I
Rita's question here about WCT and why
am i bringing a very a vocabulary based
on religion to sort of talk about 1971
are both connected issues one is
multiple issues for multiple reason one
is this language comes out from my own
the interviews and the discussions I had
I didn't make this up insomnia Torah
Hammond taba not my words they are not
my vocabulary this vocabulary was used
almost by all audio speakers whether it
was in Pakistan or Bangladesh okay in
different ways they didn't invoke God
and here as I said God is out of the
story this the concept of guna is not a
concept that is done against God it is
done against people and that's what
people remind reminded me over and over
again that unless our countries allow us
to speak about it it remains our
individual problem and that individual
problem is something that they're
interrogating why should it be our
internal problem our individual problem
where the nation and state had called
upon us to do these acts or have used us
as a body ok so the language comes from
there and i am using it perhaps
highlighting it even more because i'm
talking about two muslim countries where
islamization has become the violent kind
i'm turning it back using as i said
abdullahi am names work of a kinder
gentler islam maybe this vocabulary
coming from the people will resonate ok
why are you can you ask i am using I
o'connor's by takeoff point because I'm
starting the story after 1947 we can't
go to south side and save science
writing about the Bengali as as not yet
ready for that education that he was
talking about is kind of always
connecting illegal to Pakistan Pakistan
has its own trajectory and Pakistan has
to take responsibility of what it does
are you cons particular the if the issue
of Ayub Khan that
I am highlighting is because he actually
constructed bodies like the Islamic
ideology the Central Research Institute
where fazlur rehman was very importantly
attached to the modernizing influence of
Islam creating a modern Islam in order
to create a modern Islam history had to
be rewritten in that history people had
to be identified as Pakistanis or who
have not yet become truly Pakistani and
that is what I'm emphasizing I'm not
blaming our plan I mean I'm sort of
looking at history and how history has
been written and rewritten to create a
new narrative that Willam has talked
about that this post 47 India and
Pakistan have had very different stories
compared to Bangladesh can there be a
people's kind of ways of talking Geeta
that you ask yes it would be possible
and that's what I am sort of forging I'm
trying to say that if people can talk to
one another using the vocabulary that
comes out from within their own work
perhaps a WCT not commissioned by the
nation not commissioned by the state
would be the way out but as long as it
remains confined to the national
parameter as it has been done in
Bangladesh and identifying only one
group of people as perpetrator ie in
this case jamaat-e-islami people of
Pakistan is sometimes connection and not
using the multiple voices perhaps and is
Pakistan yet ready the women have talked
about it not the others so we in fact
was very interesting i'll just give you
one little anecdote when i started the
research in pakistan i went to punjab
university and met with the graduate
students they had never been heard that
71 was so brutal so it is necessary to
bring it back to text books it's
necessary to create the discourse that
have been completely eliminated then you
can have a people-to-people dialogue
rhythm
now maybe to continue about the question
about security I think your point was
very good that we have to be clear what
we're talking about when we are at a
conference called beyond security I was
really talking about security in the
sense of the secure the security
community so the political military type
of security you are talking about human
security which of course is another type
and in that you're right Bangladesh has
made enormous advances over the last 40
years but I what I was trying to do is
show possible themes for comparison for
doing comparative studies of Pakistan
Bangladesh and India and I do feel that
the sense of security in the political
military sense in Bangladesh is
different from India and Pakistan that
first of all the Bangladesh doesn't have
nuclear devices and the other to do
Bangladesh is many Bangladeshis see
themselves as inhabitants of a small
country surrounded by a much bigger one
again a worry so when you look at
security awareness I I do think there's
a difference in Bangladesh I was trying
to sort of flag that as to Bangor eNOS
and Bangladesh eNOS that of course is
the big debate in Bangladesh again I was
trying to to see if there are
comparative advantages and first you can
think how this works in Punjab eNOS in
pakistan in India or I recently heard of
a study of gharanas in Bangladesh
and in India and showing that the two
communities of God olds have developed
different identities and I think it's
undeniable that most Bangladesh's have
developed a different identity from West
Bengal knees and yet there are all kinds
of links and connection so I really just
wanted to show that cultural
reorientation is the outcome of
geographical interventions and that is
that is an interesting theme to study
okay so next round I have one please
that's no good what I'm not entirely
sure I understood your point about
anti-war protestors and state of
exception
the the discourse around plan is done
now for instance and and I'm not saying
this in any way as you know defense of
anything the u.s. is done or other you
know foreign bars in Afghanistan at the
moment but the anti-war discourse is
also say and in fact it there's a coming
together as the US and Britain and so on
is trying very hard to you know declare
victory and you know make an orderly
retreat although not as the Ambassador
pointed out not a complete retreat and
negotiate with the Taliban the discourse
on both sides the anti-war side and the
wars the war side as it were is that the
whole democracy project was a nonsense
now you might decide that yes a
democracy project with bombs raining
down on the country is a nonsense but
the the kind of discourse is that
actually democracy isn't suitable for
Islamic countries from the anti-war side
as well certainly where I come from in
Britain this is a very strong discourse
that that people have their own systems
there's a defense of parallel legal
systems and the parallel ism of you know
more new ones being set up by for
instance a Taliban as well as the ones
that you talked about it does the
frontier crimes regulations act and yet
there have been movements on the ground
in Pakistan of people who are demanding
that that they actually are subjected to
a system of laws so on the one hand it
may be protesting about drone attacks
and so on and that's kind of state of
military exceptionalism but also there's
a there's a demand from radicals and
Democrats and so on for actually having
laws and not tribal law being applied so
and as I said the fret you know
presidential candidate Imran Khan is you
know also trying to do deals and say you
protect tribal law because tribal law is
the price of national security you know
don't don't make war against the state
you can have your own customs locally so
that's what I was talking about and I
find the convergence of these two
discourses it should be fundamentally
opposed to each other
very frightening convergence and leaves
no space to actually support actual
Democratic movements on the ground
because it treats the military
opposition to the US as the thing that
the anti-war movement should be
supporting in other words it's
supporting another war party it's not an
anti-war movement am I think my one
comment on that would be as we know from
a lot of work on colonialism in British
India is that the notion of tribal law
is itself a kind of colonial invention
or reinvention I mean for example that
the jirga which is the local tribunal
that's administered its criminal justice
in the tribal territories is totally
reinvented by the British under the
frontier crimes regulation so that
Jurgis didn't customarily determine
guilt or innocence they tended to broker
kind of political alliances or deal with
political conflict and then under the
British fronter crimes regulation the
Jirga is transformed into this
alternative tribunal that when you look
at the records is actually meant to sort
of form a complementary system with
colonial law for in the colonial period
for example cases would often be sent to
jirga when the district officer the
British officer in the middle of the
trial would realize there wasn't enough
evidence under British colonial law to
convict the accused and so to secure
some kind of conviction they would send
this case to Jurgis Durga's not some
autonomous domain of you know tribal
practice yoga itself is reinvented by
colonial administrators who are seeking
to stabilize colonial power in in some
fashion Imran Khan he's speaking in
columbia today or tomorrow I haven't
right now it's sort of we should be
there but i'm not sure that Emraan Khan
is really a spokesperson for tribal
people in fata territories so yeah okay
one more round of questions and we have
you begin as one there and konchem there
hi my name is amina jamal and i'm from
University in Toronto I had a question
for yes mean I just found your whole
presentation very interesting because I
lived through 71 I moved to Pakistan and
I've been going back to Bangladesh and
so that's just a little bit of history
that i want to just flag here what I
found really interesting was your
discussion of perpetrators and their
understanding of their own sin Ghana and
I understand the language that you use
that is the typical Urdu speaking
language but what I found really
interested struck me was the contrast
between those internalized states and
their own understanding of their what
they had done or the emotion compared to
the what's happening in Pakistan oh and
also globally and encouraged through
scholarship scholarly work and a kind of
construction of Islam which is more
practice based and scriptural based and
I just am wondering if in your analysis
have you do you feel that the kind of
Islam that has been constructed since
the 1970s due to you know what we might
call politicized Islam and the supported
by of course Saudi Arabia and the oil
wealth and everything does that not
lessen the possibility of of this kind
of you know acceptance of an emotional
state on the part of of guilt or Ghana
and tawba on the part of individual
soldiers is they're also not one of the
factors that might be preventing that
from happening even if there were
individuals and would that even be
legitimate legitimized in both
Bangladesh and Pakistan worried to take
place at the level of individual actors
because we know the suicide bombing for
instance is almost condoned by
the kind of Islam that we are seeing in
practice and Pakistan and elsewhere yes
so I had rather long way to go I'm David
Lewis from London School of Economics
it's more comment really than a question
just while we're on the on the subject
of geographies and identities and
insecurities we haven't really talked
about environmental natural elements of
the geographies and it seems to me a
particularly interesting dimension
particularly of the ways in which
historically in a bangladeshi identity
at least amongst outsiders has been
strongly informed by notions of
environmental and security and and there
have also of course now been all of the
climate change issues and everything to
that feed into that and with also the
history of for example flood control
your efforts which have taken place in
both east and west and of course with
the floods in Pakistan recently
tremendous international attention and I
believe that the the Bangladesh NGO brac
even sent people to Pakistan to to
assist with flood relief and it seems to
me there might be some very interesting
channels and linkages and things around
those kinds of geographies which will
spring into the discussion and speak
about the implications of the
differences between both for the quality
of democracy to differences that strike
me in particular is you also have an
elite in Pakistan based on trade and
industry but you have an elite in
Pakistan that is perhaps more dependent
on land then in Bangladesh and you also
have an elite in Pakistan that is maybe
an older elite by but by that I mean
multiple generations whereas in
Bangladesh it is sometimes
second-generation but very often first
generation and I just wondered if this
is relevant at all for the quality of
democracy in both countries and if you
could speak to that cried throwing just
one last question on using my privileges
check
and this is actually actually connected
to connect Elizabeth's paper with with
yes means because in in Elizabeth's
paper the description you give of this
this condition of you know almost the
normality of the state of exception as
it were it's particularly relevant for
the frontier right where in fact
something like tyranny can be carried
out in accordance with the law okay but
that's justified because the frontier is
as it were a state that's fairly almost
indistinguishable from a state of war
it'sit's there's this there's this kind
of constant state of war and and that
rhetoric is very much present in in in
the kind of extracts you you quote that
that's what I thought was interesting in
terms of connecting this to yes means
argument because in a situation of war
and what are the demands of justice
right what is a crime in a condition of
war and these are of course you know
questions that we are very concerned
with now all over the world because of
the new emphasis on the concepts such as
crime against humanity etc because if
you if you think of the and I completely
agree with your emphasis that this is a
language which is coming out of as it
were ordinary language of ordinary
people right ideas of in sanya etc etc
guna and the interesting problem here is
that are they actually seeking a form of
forgiveness right or reconciliation
mediated by the state or is it an ocean
where the state actually does not
necessarily have any role to play if the
state has a role to play then of course
you have completely new kinds of
concerns
if it's a crime is there a punishment
for it right because the popular notion
does not seem to have an idea of you
know the victim actually inflicting
punishment so so that's the kind of
concern that that your presentation
seems to raise it's it's it's a it's a
complicated question but but yeah please
now Elizabeth I yes what I'm suggesting
is that in your case of course you know
it's it's a question of the state being
fundamentally the actor and what you
have described in terms of these areas
even today in Pakistan you seem to be
suggesting that this is a concern of the
state largely okay because even there
you could presumably have the kinds of
things that yes means talking about you
could have killings and so on so forth
but forgiveness reconciliation all kinds
of things where the state doesn't
necessarily have anything to do a role
to play but yeah
sorry I was sent from Bangladesh I just
wanted to just add a little writer to
your question to both Elizabeth and
yasmeen I was kind of astounded by the
absence of any discussion about justice
and accountability and as you said the
lack of any construction of what's going
on in terms of crimes and offenses and
the response to that and also kind of
astounded by the absence of a discussion
of what a victims rights might be the
victims perceptions of what may be
possible may be constrained by a whole
host of realities and experiences of
Justice being highly inaccessible but
you seem to reinforce the notion that
justice is just not part of the
discussion is over particularly in your
case starting with our luck you not
mentioning anything about the offenses
or the allegations are about or lucky at
all similarly in the context of talking
about war crimes in Bangladesh I think
it's important that you play you know
you talked about context somehow being
an excuse for saying rule of law is
relative but context is relevant you
can't talk about these things in
abstractor and in both your cases I
think what we didn't hear was the
context in which the entire exercise
again so lucky was mounted and we didn't
hear the context about the kinds of war
crimes and the campaigns for justice not
for reckons I don't know of any campaign
for reconciliation in bondage to be
honest never heard of it in 40 years but
I have heard a very strangled voices for
justice which are now finding some kind
of outlet so I just like a response from
both I mean in the air lock key case we
don't exactly know what the allegations
against him are nor do we know what the
evidence is supporting him that's that's
the point it was a sort of
state-authorized killing that we're told
is followed secret proceedings and
deliberations by the Obama
administration we don't know what those
are likewise in this case I mean some of
the connections I see between my paper
and yes mean are around questions of
history and memory I didn't this work
I've struggled I mean I struggle with
this notion of the fanatic as a colonial
construction nobody identifies him
herself as a fanatic and so the fanatic
becomes a figure in in this in this law
and the problem is because there's no
recordings of these proceedings
it can sometimes be hard to suss out
exactly what what happened what were
these different individuals who are
lumped together under this kind of
constructed cattery category of fanatic
thinking or feeling and you know that's
an old question that people who work on
colonial knowledge struggle with which
is is there is there a real reality that
is opposed to this colonial construction
I mean I think I think not but on the
other hand in terms of questions of
history and memory the violence of the
British state against people in this
area is a living memory there are for
example there's a very famous figure who
some of you may have heard of pakistanis
ajab khan afridi who he kidnaps he kills
a British woman wife of an officer in
the 1920s and kidnaps her daughter and
escapes into the hills and is initially
branded a fanatic and pursued as such
but because he escapes British power it
becomes increasingly impossible to refer
to him as a fanatic because he's not
motivated by any kind of religious means
he there's I won't get into that whole
story but the point about a job khan
afridi is his memory of him as a local
hero is quite strong in Peshawar there's
statues about him there's sort of
conferences that celebrate his heroic
resistance to British rule but he forms
a kind of exceptional figure I'm I'm
using exact word exception too much but
in a way because he evades the violence
of this state we can attribute a little
more subject to be doing subjectivity to
him and understand a little bit better
how he's remembered in the region now as
for the question of why wrote down what
becomes a crime but that wasn't the
question of it being a constant state of
war on the frontier the relevant
question is state and non-state how
what what is you know or your
description is very much with the stated
century yeah are their procedures
processes but non state forms of
negotiation well my emphasis in this
particular work is on Indians who kill
British officers so that's always seen
by the state as an act against the state
the British in the region are also
really taken by the notion that this is
an inherently violent population they
estimate when they first take control of
peshawar in 18-49 they estimate that
there's one murder per day and kept a
shower is seen as the capital you know
the sort of capital murder of india for
for most of the British period and
there's all kinds of different ways that
the British attempt to control and Riaan
lesson violence within Indian society
including this construction of the durga
system which which they hope is going to
reduce tribal feuds and vendetta's but
but my point here is just to show how
you know violence with within and within
sort of tribal society is if it is of
concern and there are efforts to control
it but it's the violence against the
British officer that that elicits this
kind of you know wildly you know
exaggerated response okay I'm going to
take all those questions together I
think about those question about what is
considered to be a crime during war and
I and your question Sarah about what
kinds of crimes are committed are very
interesting when it comes out from the
testimonies of of the soldiers
themselves and one thing I do want to be
I do want to attain here highlight here
is when we are talking of this 1971 war
there is no one group of perpetrator if
it came out like as if only the
Pakistanis we're doing violence I beg my
bag I apologize it is not the case it
has been done by all groups of people so
when we talk try to talk about a context
we have taken two crimes who is the
victim that is I think the biggest
question that as I think commentators
now we have to ask we cannot take sides
with national questions and say only one
group is a popular other is not
the question of state maybe is one of
the relevant issues in there the state
of Pakistan did use its army at that
time East Pakistan was part of Pakistan
it was not yet Bangladesh right so it
was seen as the session ism treason
which was not which is also a crime
against state now when the when the
soldiers recovery call this event they
do say that there are certain
permissibility when you go toward a
certain permissible crime like week
occupied territory the guerrillas who
are destroying our tanks they have taken
the help of our enemy India that's kind
of permissible violence because
combatants fighting against combatants
when combatants I'm not fighting against
combatants but using terror it is
considered to be a crime and this crime
is committed by men against women at
this period in time in history rape is
not yet considered to be a war crime we
know that it happens only after the
Bosnian war so that crime now needs to
be revisited can we redraw actively use
the case of 1971 as recording as a war
crime a crime against humanity crime
against women as rape is left to the
lawyers I supposed to ask that question
how mother Ramon Commission did talk
about it it is not like Pakistan didn't
talk about it because I'm talked about
it it was not made public so people who
have to deal with this issue as you are
raising continues to be an internal
struggle because the states have not
recognized it is it possible to continue
with this narrative with the rising
trend of as you said an islamization
that is very aggressive sometimes I have
to ask that question myself with the
attack on so many Sufi shrines in
Pakistan which I think some of this
narrative comes out of that kind of
syncretic tradition over and over again
people did talk about zamil conscience
my conscience and all my interviews are
based from 2004 so it's 30 years after
the war that people are still able to
talk about this but this big question is
what is what is the state and the people
here and how do we see the role of the
state in this particular
case it's a very very complicated issue
actually and I don't know how to answer
it except bring it out to the forefront
to say there are multiple narratives of
1971 which one are we willing to hear
and which are not the ones that the
state wants to hear tahira mazhar ali
has been continuing the struggle for a
very long time with him I think Janaki
is going look at worry so maybe we
should stop it no ok we'd over thank you
very much for good opening session